entre prairies vignes et forêts à blanot
le vert est partout et s'affiche même
dans les urnes ici la liste conduite par
yannick jadot a réuni 41,86 % des voix
un résultat qui n'a pas surpris le maire
de ce village le changement climatique
on le perçoit ici avant pour sortir du
village au col là qui est inquiète à 500
mètres à la sortie du village
il ya deux cols un de chaque côté
souvent pendant l'hiver on avait des
périodes de neige de 2
les deux cols étaient difficilement
praticables et encore 10 12 ans
aujourd'hui ça n'arrive jamais une
sensibilité pour la nature et l'écologie
que ce maire partage avec ses
administrés on sauve coco poil f1 qu'au
bois du coup et là dessus à la mairie
nous aide aussi parce qu'un droit
d'affouage qui permet de couper le bois
qui rentre dans les dans les champs qui
nous avait coûté le bois pour qu'on
puisse se chauffer du coup gratuitement
c'est un échange de bons procédés qui
est chouette
du coup blanot un territoire rural
ici on compte un peu plus de 15 %
d'agriculteurs soit cinq fois plus qu'à
l'échelle nationale certains d'entre eux
espèrent que le résultat des élections
européennes permettra de verdir encore
davantage la commune on est une commune
qui est un petit peu en cuvette qui a
des limites et géographiquement qui a
des limites qu'on voit bien en fait cédé
toutes les craintes autour des fois on
est déjà pas mal il ya déjà une autre
ferme en bio non se fasse on fait de la
conversion est en conversion on a un
voisin aussi la kiki et pas sur la
commune mais qui exploitent des terres
en bio ici je fais pas des fois je me
dis ça ça pourrait être sympa d'avoir
une commune vraiment orienté presque à
100% sur le bio mais abla nos communes
de 170 habitants la tendance verte devra
se confirmer lors des prochaines
échéances électorales en 2014 lors des
dernières élections européennes blanot
avait placé edouard martin et sa liste
union de gauche en tête